good evening counselors I will do the
emergency evacuation should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building via the
nearest emergency available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be the
public car parked at the side of the
Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded please
put your phones on silent thank you can
you now please be upstanding to receive
the Chairman the Chairman's chaplain and
the managing director
good evening members please remain
standing for prayers but before I ask
Reverend David dr. to be to give prayers
I'd like to welcome him very much to
this meeting and to thank him for
agreeing to be my chaplain for the
current year
thank you let us pray
gracious and merciful God do you have
blessed each one of us with particular
distinct responsibilities unique roles
and gifts and we as those gathered
gathered members with those particular
responsibilities in our communities we
come before you we pray and ask that you
would lead them lead us in all wisdom
you would guide us by your Holy Spirit
the gracious Lord we would have a common
mind to the good of our communities with
which we serve we pray O Lord that your
presence would be with us so Lord we
offer ourselves we offer this time and
we offer all of our gifts unto you and
to our communities bless as this evening
in our deliberations we pray
this procedure
I'll start with the first item on the
agenda apologies for absence and I have
apologies from councillor drain
councillor mrs lammle councillor
mountain councillor autumn counselor
Deanna and council panel are there any
other apologists
now in the absence of counselor Trey as
vice-chairman the immediate past
chairman has agreed to sit here keep an
eye on me and generally assist me during
the meeting item 2 on the agenda is the
minutes of the annual meeting held on
the 15th of May 2018 are those agreed
members thank you
item 3 to receive declarations of
interest counselor but thank you I need
to declare a pecuniary interest in item
number 13 at that point I will leave the
meeting this evening
there we go yes it is members it seems a
bit of an odd microphone tonight it's on
but the red lights not so not showing
I'd like to announce that my chosen
charity for this year is the stroke
stroke unit at South End Hospital which
I hope will meet with the approval of
members generally I think it's a
fantastic unit I paid a visit to them on
Monday and had a tour around there and I
was very impressed by what they're doing
and indeed what they're hoping to do in
the in the future with charity donations
such as the amount I'm hoping to raise
this year okay item five I beg your
pardon
council card more we can get this one
yes I thought I thought you liked works
on this one so I'm not too bad well I
just like to say something if I may
about the flags that have been put up in
our district ordinates and Georgie's
flags and the support for our England
team which I thought was fantastic and I
think it deserves acknowledgement in the
minutes for this council to see all
those players going up yes our boys
didn't win Young Lions but they
certainly did us proud and I'd like that
acknowledging the committee in the
minutes and to thank and the members of
the public that actually did that
because I think it was a great sight to
look at all the flags that were around
the district and I really appreciate it
and I'm sure many members do yeah I
think it's a good idea good idea
okay item 5 public questions and member
questions on notice there are none six
item six business from the last council
meeting
there's none seven two notes the minutes
of executive and committee meetings held
between the
period 16th a 4 to 6 July 2018 as
visited is that noted members thank you
item 8 now I wonder whether I might take
8 1 & 8 3 together as they both relate
to reviews of the Constitution does any
member have any objection to that so we
take the both of those together council
person would you like to thank you
chairman members will have seen that the
attach reports with the recommendations
put forward by the review committee and
although at first glance it may appear
that the reports are extensive the
proposed changes are fairly
self-explanatory and were initially
agreed by the working party oversee in
this task with significant input
assistance from the assistant director
Angela law and Paul Gower's their
proposals were then considered by a
review committee who agreed these and
put forward the recommendation before
members this evening if any members have
got any questions or queries Angela law
myself or the chairman of the working
party would be happy to try an answer or
address those questions Kelso Campbell
I have a few queries actually chairman
if I may may I first go to page
let's see page ten eight one ten top of
the page there towards the top ten point
three where it says no decent questions
a question may only be asked if notice
has been given by delivering it in
writing belt by electronic mail to the
managing director no later than midday
on the day of the meeting chairman I
think that's far too short a notice for
us to actually respond properly
particularly if we have a question
that's of a technical nature I have
knowledge the fact that you know we need
to give time for people to put their
questions in once the agenda has been
issued or you know the particular
question may be asked on that particular
agenda so I propose if I may to make
that three days
I'm have to second that chair but I'll
reserve the right to speak chill I said
I've got a number of others if I may
continue yeah and then perhaps members
might want to debate all the others as
well on page that's a page eight four
point five I think so yes
well I think that's up to members really
a page 84.5 where it says after the
organ remembers committee or
subcommittee has notified member
servicing writer by email confirming who
will be there nominated substitute and
specifying the committee or subcommittee
twenty-four hours before the date of the
meeting at the latest German I'd like
that whole paragraph three
there is no paragraph two I'm here to be
deleted I'm on four point five chairman
which is page eight one eight page one
eight
thank you
germander and the circumstances of
somebody who's attending a meeting night
might well be at the last minute and of
course there wouldn't be time to be able
to do that
I accept that we have elsewhere that
they should know what's actually in the
agenda for that meeting but I think it's
wrong not to give the appropriate to
give that amount of notice when
certainly personal emergencies he only
sees may happen so I'd like that three
deleted tomb thank you
on page again for post by five one where
are we five one see if we can find it
I'm just well looking for
so it's very difficult to work from two
things at the same time it's basically
it's a very minor one it was changing a
who to whom I think that was in 4.5 but
I think you've just proposed alright
okay fair enough
and in page six page 14 point O 3 point
fourteen point O three if we can find
that where it says the first sentence is
contradicted by the second sentence and
I'll read it to you chairman it says
approval changes to the Constitution
will only be approved by the full
council after consideration of the
proposal by the monitoring officer and
then it says such other changes of a
factual nature as may seem appropriate
to make the Constitution internally
consistent up to date may be made by the
monitoring officer in consultation with
the stanzas committee I'll just think
you I can't see that link there it's
page eight one six
so
yes or 2.03 I turn a so I just wanted to
comment on that chairman if I may
thank you
personally I think the second alteration
I would have no issue with personally by
word ups to obvious least seek
clarification from other members I
personally don't see any reason why the
last proposed change should be made at
all this was actually a debated quite a
lot within the working party and with
Angela law with regards to changes or
minor changes and it was felt that it
would be to Labour's them for minor
changes to have to go through the whole
entire process of coming to Council
which was why it was decided that the
monitoring officer really should be
given the authority to make those
changes and they are very very minded
changes not constitutional changes as
such I think you could correct me if I'm
wrong the council cut law isn't
objecting to the principle here but
merely saying that the second sentence
is inconsistent with first centers
because you come and have an unqualified
instruction in the first sentence and
then qualified in your circumstances mmm
I'll be fair that's some honest officers
I think that was something you use self
will happy bits though
okay counselor Burton's right in that
any substantial changes are to be
referred for counsel and the idea
between behind this amendment is to
allow for factual nature so for example
if there's been any legislators to I
don't know say for example there's now a
designated Data Protection Officer
that's alleged to have change that's the
factual nature we have to add that to
the Constitution I mean perhaps rather
things they're saying such other changes
what could we put em up to suggestions
members however other changes of a
factual and minor nature the first
using the word subject is hearing off
the measurements sorry chairman I
couldn't so it's subjective if you
really inserts a be immediately before
changes of the in the first line subject
is hearing after mentioned okay and then
you've got the qualification I mean
happy with but it's just the explanation
as to why that's there can't go so I
rather took over I do apologize it's
alright submerge him I think you've got
the the tryst of who I'm all about so
that's fine I'm happy with that because
it qualifies it next one I want to look
at if I'm a chairman is page let's see
for a which is eight one eight this
sorry it's not page 4a it's points four
eight eight one for a sorry oh yes it's
that one that's why in trouble with it
where it says open scrutiny procedure
rules changes as per appended working
group recommends that the chairman of
review should be draw from either the
main opposition group the main
opposition group or nominated by the
opposition groups it should be noted
that council decision minute one four
nine zero seven is that the chairman of
review should be a member from the
opposition chairman that's not the case
at the moment certainly and I'd like
that deleted but I understand from
colleagues that at the review committee
that was actually deleted anyway I don't
if anybody can confirm that for me
so I'm having difficulty finding that
could you just confirm his pager let's
see the appendix chairman eight one four
a thank you on the set on the second
page of the appendix bless you
thank you okay thank you very much do I
have a seconder for that please there's
two seconds thank you
right and I think that's it as far as
that's concerned I think as far as that
particular paper is concerned okay
I'm happy for members to ask questions
or debate this what I'm suggesting this
Thank You page eight one eight item four
point five castle cap more requested
that the item marked as three is deleted
but the item with would changing who to
whom is in the first line item one to
take place of the only member for whom
there are designated subject okay so
just as a point of correction before I
speak the second yeah thank you very
much
counselor mrs. Mason
we will be slightly confused by the lack
of sequencing on the questions would it
be possible for someone to summarize
those in some sort of order so that we
can see because at the moment I'm
totally confused as to what has been
suggested and not being suggested Thank
You calories
Thank You mr. point of clarity for my
the three days notice suggested by
counsel that more can that be clarified
as three working days or three actual
calendar days
thank you yeah in my position as chair
the review committee and in consultation
with the chairman of the working party
we don't we don't have any issues with
the the proposed changes made by Terry
come on counselor come on sign thank you
careful captain would you like to just
summarize those
on page eight one six three
[Music]
[Music]
three working days
our members play over there this is
counsel mr. Mason
I can't hear with that on so perhaps we
could open the windows instead I can't
you don't hear that
thank you
sorry it's a lack of clarity perhaps the
gentleman could be allowed to remove
their jackets
I'm very good good let's just have some
clarity over 10.3 plays that was going I
don't think I've got any objections or
anything said I just want there some
clarity about and can we just be told
what 10.3 will now read please in
relation to three date for you we give
three days
is it midday three days before seems
like I don't know what they threw you
chairman all I'm changing is three
working days notice from the same day
thank you
but instead of seven days it's gonna be
three working days that is correct isn't
it there's a heretic Roger say is only
three no later than midday three working
days before the day of the meeting yes
thank you can we all agree on that or do
you want to vote is that agreed members
you have a vac very well all those in
favor of those amendments please say so
thank you and those against
any abstentions
that's carried thank you
we'll go to item 8 to the reporter there
those two together
um
and move now to item 8 3
I do apologize eight 8/2 we've taken 81
and 83 together item 8 2
do I do Thank You chairman yep as
members will say the review committee
considered a suggestion to look at the
recent consultation that was carried out
and respected the hospital mergers after
considering several different options
the committee felt that it was the
recommendation contained within the trip
will be the most appropriate with the
invite for situating for council and
it's very self-explanatory any questions
we'll take them thank you
is that agreed members great thank you
I donate for the report of the review
committee treasury management annual
review 2017-18
council person thank you again chairman
this is one of three reports on treasury
management that the review committee
reviews on an annual basis as members
will see this report provides a review
of the 2017-2018 period and therefore
the information contained within the
report is mostly historic again any
questions please ask no me lo or
councillor Smith the portfolio holder
for Finance are there any questions
members all if not is that noted
they noted thank you
item eight-six miss one sorry item eight
five report to the planning policy
subcommittee in respect to the local
development screen twenty eighteen to
twenty one councillor stone Thank You
chairman I think the reports have been
submitted for this meeting of pretty
comprehensive but quite lengthy which is
not a patch on what we were subjected to
and having to read the paperwork that we
were submitted approach a thousand pages
now while we fully appreciated that this
wasn't within at times
officers control it was supplementary
information from other councils it did
concern us greatly the the whole issue
that this generated as a result of this
we have recommended and and it's already
been done tree actions that we have a
meeting of the subcommittee on a monthly
basis even if it's only for a 30-minute
catch-up as to where we're going this is
no criticism of officers or their
abilities but it is the sheer volume of
work that they are being subjected to
there's a very strong and solid
timetable that they're required to work
to we are fully aware that central
government is already watching this area
very closely with regard particularly to
Basildon Castle Point and Brentwood and
we don't want to be come under any
scrutiny from central government want to
make sure that we've got our house in
order and again that we have expressed
in these reports our concern about
resources levels for officers in purely
in light of the amount of work they are
going to be subjected to them over the
next year's I think that pretty much
sums up our Buchanon essa off if
anybody's got any questions they want to
raise but I think the volume of work
that will need to be done over the next
few years needs to be monitored closely
we are quite prepared as a subcommittee
to do that but we do want to
that concerns that we have the officers
will be able to manage some of this
Thank You German Thank You mr. white
Thank You Jerry
I'm just a couple of first money aside I
do have concerns about the ability to
keep to the timetable as it gears up and
said we're not just what we can do is
also by national government and also our
local councils from other areas which
bring me on to the next point I did
raise this brief very brief discounters
bearing but also it's the managing
director because I had I do have some
concerns about how the seller or
Association of South a six local
authorities and the state in the common
ground and the what would appear to be
an overarching local plan befitting with
our local code
now I'm aware that we as a council Ora
the head of other authorities within
that organization but I am concerned
that it would have when we read the
assent of documents it definitely gives
the impression that there will be a an
overarching plan for the South Essex
area eventually and I'm wondering and on
look at me by the Senate by 2050 so
sometime between now and 2050 there'll
be a plan in place which would be an
overarching one for the whole area now
I've got concerns whether that is
top-down or bottom-up Isaac come and
kind of come from us as a local council
feeding into that or is it going to come
from the combined local authorities
feeding down into what we should be
doing so I hope that's an understable
question the phone Carrie could answer
I'm not sure okay clearly but I'd be
grateful thank you well I I haven't got
a crystal ball
so on that basis whatever I say I think
he's gonna be a bit of a wing and a
prayer answer however I understand for
me to come or he will okay I'll come
what he will be elaborating on this when
he speaks later
yeah I said you know you have raised
okay thank you
any other questions that's been the
recommendation is that's the council
resolves that they dropped local
development scheme 2018 to 2021
as attached as Appendix 1 be adopted is
that agreed members now passed to item 8
six report of the Investment Board
Council step 2 Thank You chairman as
discussed at the investment board this
report sets out an opportunity to invest
in in the upkeep of hopfully public
toilets and to hand them over to Holly
parish council to look after there are
three options outlined in the report to
to the Investment Board each option
would allow the council to save on the
annual cleaning and maintenance costs
and provide the public with a better
facility at this stage sorry at this
stage
Hockley Parish Council have not
finalized their preference but to ensure
flexibility and maintain the momentum
and negotiations that is requested that
the authority delegated to the offices
to finalize the lease arrangements and
I'd like to propose the recommendation
that is on 86 1/2 2
any questions members Council Chairman
as members will know our members of the
public will know that we invested
heavily in toilets in our local areas
this has been a long negotiation he's
still going on with hopefully we
certainly settled it with several of the
other councils as members are aware so
this is really just about putting the
budget in place so that we can get that
done there are other factors that do
come in to it but at least we know that
we've got the budget and we're waiting
for reports from other development that
may have happened nearby but certainly
not within a you know quite a long time
frame as we understand it but I
certainly have to report support the
recommendation coming forward chin thank
you no more questions the recommendation
is that it is proposed that council
resolves that on completion of the lease
negotiations with Hockley parish council
authority be delegated to the assistant
director environmental services in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for environment to undertake
installation or the refurbishment
replacement of public conveniences with
an allocated capital budget of up to 88
thousand pounds ourself set out in the
office of reports there's agreed members
item eight seven
Ketel web would you like to present this
one Thank You mr. chairman first law
provides recognized their work that
Sumari and the co B team have carried
out and delivering the valuable and
important service in our district which
provides support 94 residents but also
helps to support our own council
services to manage demands in housing
and our webs and benefits services the
service needs Scouts the market now as
the current contract expires next year
and I'm pleased that we're proposing to
do so and we're looking to continue to
maintain the current level of service
provision that our residents enjoy just
like your members attention to some of
the following highlights in the appendix
if I can firstly in 3.5 the current
advice service contract has demonstrated
social value and value for money in 1617
receive of every pound invested by the
council's 51 pounds has returned into
the local economy saving accounts or 2
pounds for every pound and also in 1718
local incomes have been increased by an
estimated four hundred and eighty six
thousand pounds I'd also like job meant
to adorn members attention to such 23.6
analysis has been undertaken but the
impact of the reduction of the value of
the contract which highlighted that even
a 10% reduction in the price paid for
the contract would have a significant
impact on the number of clients that
could be seen a week by the service
so in order to provide sustainability
for the service it is suggested that the
contract will be two years with the
option of a further year
simply put twelve on contract is a
political value because of the lack of
security that it offers in addition
outdoor members attention 28.2 in the
appendix where it is stated that within
the contract it will be it is
anticipated the counter owned
accommodation used for the current
service provided at the civic suite by a
batplane Watford or continues to be made
available at a peppercorn length that
said council owned assets are under
constant review at one of its priorities
in the current business plan be
maximizing assets
therefore the provide will be expected
to discuss and consider future
accommodation options throughout the
period of the contract finally on the
first page section 1.3 I would just like
one of them to be made to report please
and that is a removal of the face to
note as a report should read that the
council resolves that the advice service
contract beer attended rather than
resolves to note that the advice service
contract beer attended therefore I would
like to propose at the council results
that the advice service contract beer
attended for further tea appeared for
the option for counts to extend the
contract to a further one year and that
the value of the contract continued to
be seventy thousand pounds
thank you chairman thank you any
questions
councillor mr. Lee Thank You chairman
just couple of the one question type of
officer observations one is in perhaps
E's normal per term I don't often come
across tenders where we actually known
the price before we actually do the
tender I've asked questions around this
with officers but unfortunately sure I
think must have been off and hasn't been
able to reply
could we in future cause it there are
some people have been rather confused
because there's a the 70,000 pen is
often referred to within the grounds as
well and I think that should now be
totally divorced for many many matron of
grounds and would that be possibly in
the future for thinking to some people
who look like they gained the grand
seventy thousand and also their
tendering for 70,000 because the Vice
written I understand that we understand
but it looks that way and I've had
questions on that
before tonight the second point is
paragraph a point to which counselor
Webber's mentioned in relation to count
paragraph nine point two I think they
can be read as contradictory to some
extent 922 says the successful bidder
will be granted the use of counsel
premises in the on a license I should on
a license for neutral two years to be
grown seed I'm getting affected it's
free by the by the terminology of that
however all obviously in paragraph a
pointers being pointed out the provider
might be expected to discuss this in
previously we have had values put on
that is that value available and that's
the question Aston unfortunate office
wasn't around I'm not sure if the
capsule with he's aware of the value of
that or not or if the any success or any
bidders for the contract of beating that
would be indicated to them what the cost
is Thank You counsel whip Thank You
counselor so you take your first point
back to taken forward in terms of the
value the estimative only about six
thousand pounds as that's comparable
with other contracts it was discussed
whether that should be included in the
value of the contract it was felt to do
so would actually to reduce the value of
the contract and that would they have an
impact on our residents which is why I
thought it would be better to keep it as
it is but I take your point in terms of
9.2 and 8.2 I asked that to be clarified
of offices
you're happy with it - councilman Howser
is amazing
I'm sorry - go back from the same point
mr. chairman but I've had extreme
difficulty in hearing councillor Webb
not sure he's been clear but I haven't
be able to hear because he had overhead
noise and I'm having difficulty
participating because of that if
councillor cap Moore is now comfortable
enough could we again ask for the
air-conditioning to be turned off so I
can fully hear the meeting thank you
III have to say that I share your
concern in relation to not being able to
hear but I think that's largely because
counsel we're speaking a little bit
quietly but
chaos
sir if you'll permit me I'll go and
fiddle with it as I always used to it
might help if you'll give me just a
moment yes by all means we'll see what
we can do
I think if I've correctly understood
what counsel we're saying is that the
the it is now proposed that the council
resolves delete the words to note yeah
so it it now reads it is proposed that
council resolves that the advice
services contract BRE tendered for a
further two year period with the option
for the council to extend the contract
for a further one year and that the
value of the contract continued to be
seventy thousand pounds it's never grave
lenders thank you I think
council business racing should answer
that question are you happy with that we
can you know can you now here item nine
report on urgent decisions there are
none item ten report of the leader of
the work of the Executive Council it
thank you chairman I think the members
will have a copy of this on their desks
chairman this is the first ordinary
council meeting of the 2018-19
municipal year and i would like to
welcome all members since the meeting on
the 24th of april the executive has met
twice during which considerations
included the provisional out turn
position against the 2017-18 revenue
budget the REIT ending of the advice
services contract 20 19 22 with the
options of the counts were to extend the
contract for a further one year the
implementation plan for the economic
growth strategy and associated key
performance indicators the process and
the outcomes of contract monitoring for
the council was most significant
contracts in terms of contract value and
risk and the latest version of the
project's management
program management office dashboard in
other matters that my colleagues and I
on the executive of dealt with include
the improving the air quality action
plan for Rayleigh for submission to the
Department of Environment Food and Rural
Affairs and agreeing that the card
payment facility is not updated and is
disabled for a trial period of six
months all of the car park ticket
machines within the Rockford district
when the current chip-and-pin Hardware
becomes obsolete at the end of June 2018
chairman as always I will be happy to
take any questions from members in
respect of the work of the executive and
I'm sure my executive colleagues will be
happy to contribute where appropriate
thank you thank you yes mr. Mason Thank
You chairman I understand that in
relation to the car payment facility
that their costs of using a phone pay
would be absorbed from the 1st of July I
was contacted by residents around the
5th 6th 7th 8th and 9th to say that that
wasn't being the case and they were
charged the assistant director told me
that it would be it would be fixed but I
guess my concern is did we refund I know
it's only a small amount but a principle
of ethics did we arrange for those
residents who were charged to be
refunded
Oh your weather mr. Hodgman would you
like to comment on that we're a small
number of instances and certainly where
they have approached us we have been
able to wait for that but of course he's
not gonna give to trace back through the
payment system it's a direct payment if
you wish so if someone has come to us
and said there was an issue then yes we
would do so and but it was a small
number and that there is some confusion
over the payment system as well I think
something to think about they're still
paying 20 pence for the child with
actually paying a two set of ten pence
for additional things in terms of
receipting they're not actually part of
the charging system so you specify up to
40 pence that's 20 pence for the
transaction of these of the car park and
charge and have additional to 10 pence
ease one is for a reminder and the other
one is for requesting a formal receipt
so that times I think people that are
still selecting for those two options
but certainly that the the actual cost
me out the transaction has been removed
but for those that have come forward yes
we have we have waited there
any other questions
item 11 emotions on notice there are
none
item 12 Association of South Essex local
authorities joint strategic plan plan
Council Kabul Thank You chairman members
may be aware of in certain press
announcements and other things that
indeed we are working with other
authorities that be in Basildon castle
Point therap Southend and Brentwood
together with Essex County Council what
I like to call the magnificent chairman
magnificent 7 chairman to see if we can
actually get some further investment in
our own area of South Essex this is an
interesting and an innovative
Association Chairman I think in the past
where you had councils such as District
Council's County Council's and unitary
council was working together
it's been called like coding cats but in
this particular occasion I think we're
actually working in unison which is a
first and I think we're the first of our
kind as well to try and actually take
this sort of thing forward now I know
that councillor has asked the question
about the any overarching plan that may
come forward from that and of course it
will be bottom-up chairman in as much as
we would have our own local plan which
would be sacrosanct to us but in
achieving that plane we may look to a
further plan which actually joins and
has synergies with other councils so
that we can actually take forward
further investment to get the numbers of
houses that we want in this area and
actually have the proper infrastructure
that would support them in our local
plan so the two things go together
chairman but of course the our own local
plan is actually the plan that we have
and we part it we're part of so as far
as the statement of common ground is
concerned it's about working towards
what got the government policies is and
we will be going going to be having
heard James growing
the meeting that he had at the inn
thorak recently he is very much
recommended to councils that they work
together we already have a duty to
cooperate with other councils and really
this is just an extension to that so we
are working with other councils nearby
to make sure that we can actually try
and extract from government as much
investment in our local area as we can
so that where we do actually build
houses and actually the industry and
other things that we have and we're not
just talking about those we're talking
about schools we're talking about health
and and open spaces as well that we we
try and get the maximum that we can so
in that context so that's what we've
been working on and there are various
strands to this that I know various
councils and their offices are working
through and I know our own particular
chief executive with these planning
experience is actually leaning on the
planning side so we have a you know
we're over playing our card on that one
which is quite an interesting place to
be and we've already got nine hundred
thousand grants from the government
planning delivery fund so it shows that
the government is actually taking real
interest in what we're doing to try and
get a result part of that results which
came before this was getting the
investment in the one to seven fair
Glynn chairman which you know would be
60 or million pounds and that's that's
been out for consultation recently and
will be coming forward in a couple of
years or so but so what we really want
is investment new things like the one
two seven that will enable growth that
we want in a planned and proper way with
the support that's needed to support
that growth so going forward I see this
as a real advantage for not just for
Oxford but for the whole of South Essex
because people do travel outside of our
own our own district into other boroughs
and other areas and so you know they
don't see necessarily the boundaries
that we see is public
sessions so I think it's important that
we actually work together to a common
goal it's already been mentioned about
brentwood Basildon and castle points
having letters from the government
saying they've got to get on with their
planes well this is also one of the
things i think that the seller the
association of southeast explorer ''tis
is also looking at to make sure that we
can actually help them as much as we can
to achieve their local plans so I see
the synergies between our local plan and
their overarching plan coming forward
together with the other local
authorities and you know it's a unique
opportunity to actually take a proper
planned approach to a whole area of
South Essex that's you know getting on
for 900,000 people I think is the figure
to make sure that we reached and part to
the east of London actually take
ourselves forward we think there's been
under investment in area in the past we
want to try to put some of that right
chin so I do commend the fact that we're
actually taking this forward and I think
the statement I think actually is ASIS
or one of the building bricks if you
like the foundations of that going
forward
Thank You Jen thank you very much Thank
You chairman clearly they will be well
maybe it isn't clear I I think that
there should be an overarching plan
coming from a seller relating to South
Essex so if that is the case and that's
a reasonable assumption and it was the
assumption I made in planning policy so
no one's disabuse me of it I then have
concerns to say is this solely going to
be decided by politicians working
together in councils or are the public
actually going to be involved in
determining whether the plan is what
they want if I remember correctly the
right honourable mr. Brogan Shire spoke
about the very real need if you're
going to have new conurbations in other
words and new developments in the form
of garden villages then these
authorities will have to take all of the
residents with them and he wants to see
that happen so I'd like to know the
plans that etcetera have got to consult
with the public consult the residents on
the plans they have if if I can draw
members attention to page 12 19 on the
report you'll see the proposed timetable
for the preparation of the joint
strategic plan and within the top
section on that page you'll see that
there's mention of regulation 18 for
example the intention is that the plan
preparation process follows exactly the
same plan preparation process as would
be the case for a local plan or a winner
minerals and waste plan that's the
legislation and rules that the
government requires us to conform to so
it will be subject to extensive public
consultation as part of the the plan
preparation process
Thank You chairman it was mentioned
there about the a12 seven and just so
members are aware in my role as County
counselor I've an in process of setting
up a task force to look at the a12 seven
and I refer to as the a12 seven economic
corridor just the a12 seven and that
would include trains as well as buses as
well as the a12 seventh outside of the
council's that council cameras mentioned
as far as a one to seven is concerned
we're also working with Havering and
also mold and it's interesting them
thank you thank you thank you mr.
chairman you'll be pleased that I'm not
going to comment on the extractor fan
it's absolutely fine and most thanks to
councillor Hudson and I've just got one
question and it's a very minor concern
on page 12 21 10.1 it says that the
local planning authorities will be asked
to make decisions based on advice now
how what weight will the planning
authority have to give to that advice
because at the moment we would consider
advice we have statutory consultation we
have other information but it the word
based and I'm not arguing about the
wording as it's obviously considered
implies some obligation there to the
planning authority which gives me a
concern that as an individual planning
authority that we might be dictated to
for want of a better word by another
body so I'd just like some confirmation
that that's not the intention I'm sure
it's not and I'm hoping I miss reading
it but I
like that confirmed thank you or
chairman I don't know if I'm reading
this wrong
I suppose it's semantics but if you look
at it it says who will be asked not will
be instructed or go join doesn't mean
decide we have to do it chairman and
I've already said that this will be
bottom up not top down but of course
there will be things that we would have
to do to conform with a plan that comes
forward and of course that's the exact
context in which we see this so you know
I think it's a bit of a nothing question
really because it's very little that you
can actually contradicting this I think
he's extremely clear chairman but just
to clarify yes we would be asked to
serve certain things because there will
be information and clarification
required on our part or our our joint
signature to any plan that covers the
whole area so I think that's very clear
term thank you chairman I hope this
isn't considered a a vague question it's
concerning item 4.1 on page 12 points to
where you've got the first indent there
it says provide a more effective way of
place shaping providing a bigger canvas
to direct development to the right areas
that deliver growth my concern there and
I'm sure the concern would be for our
residents that we are looking at their
direct development to the right areas
does that therefore mean that if it is
considered by this group that this area
would be more suitable to direct
development to that we would be subject
to more development
I know councillor Pat Moore has already
said that it will be a bottom-up issue
but this seems to almost be in
contradiction
to that
sorry Thank You chairman we early days
as far as any of this is concerned and
that's very clear chairman but of course
we do have a duty to cooperate with
you're already there and of course if we
have the right infrastructure to deliver
the housing that we're looking at indeed
that's the whole point Jim and I think
the counselor is absolutely right in
what he's saying in as much as as far as
any infrastructure is concerned that
will enable growth but you can't get one
without the other
so as far as that's concerned yes we
have to play it we have to play our part
in any cooperation that we have with
other council doesn't mean to say we
can't reject it change it not have it at
all but that's a conversation to be had
chairman and it's been there before and
it's still there so that duty to
cooperate remains are there any more
questions
I'm sorry cancer story Thank You
chairman yes just from from cancer eaves
and the concerns that I also have around
this and paragraph 9 23 you talked about
there are no housing allocation set out
in the soc G segment of government on
the ground as this will be determined
through the JSP and based on the agreed
spatial directory and updated live in
this place now that if you I understand
that we are saying or or counselor cut
Maury saying this is going to be being
prepared from what the council's are
pushing upwards if you like the concern
is that that may be the intent for quite
often intense don't always happen and it
can be and the concern is that this this
Union or audios of local authorities may
end up working the other way and I
wonder what safeguards we have I
understand that we we are not bound by
this we can leave at any time it's my
understanding is there a veto that we
have over it if one local authority does
not agree to something they can say no
that's not going to happen and still be
part of the group these I understand
okay as a couple silly it's not like
there's going to be quite I'm sure you
discuss things I think is I'm sure
that's not your attend but the concern
is that that may be overtaken by that
the final question is I've asked this at
many meetings now in the original grant
application
there was an own award made for cost to
the previously prepared
Sh'ma can we please see if any of that
money is time to come back to Rockford
I've asked the question I've been told
it will be looked at and I have still
not had an answer thank you I'm gonna
answer the second question chairman as
far as the first question is concerned
yes thank you Jim if I mean in relation
to the second question we'll take that
back and make sure there's a response
thank you in that case the
recommendation is the council resolves
to approve the statement of common
ground prepared by the Association of
South Essex of local authorities as set
out in the appendix to this report to
guide the preparation of the joint
strategic plan for South Essex if
they're agreed members
item 13 lease of the house in multiple
occupation property in Oxford King's
Head 11 West Street Rochford careful
with Thank You mr. chairman represent
their watch of District Council's
planning to offer 11 self-contained
rooms at the king's head 11 West Street
Rochford to individuals who urge ibly
need to be housed the three ground-floor
properties will be used for commercial
purposes this will ensure that people
who are currently already suffering a
great deal of upheaval in their lives
can continue to live in the district and
maintain their local ties and support
networks there are currently over 18
households in temporary accommodation
and over 25% of these have had to be
placed in emergency accommodation
outside of the district which causes
disruption to local residents as well as
a significant cost to their council
taxpayer the use of 11 West Street will
and also enable the authority to make a
cost saving of approximately 50,000
pounds per year if as a council we do
not take this opportunity then we risk
these properties going to a housing
provider from out of the area and
putting residents into our area do not
on our estates this way we remain
controlled in control of the property
and have exclusive nomination rights
that can help our residents if this is a
great start before council then it is
plan that residents of businesses will
be invited to attend drop-in sessions to
hear about the plans to provide
much-needed temporary housing in watch
your tone sensor to drop-in sessions are
are planned or watcher - council rooms
on the 30th of July the local residents
and businesses will be personally
invited by letter
therefore I'm pleased to recommend to
the council the recommendations and 8.1
the council resolves that a 10-year
lease to be entered into the king's head
11 West Street watch furred and the
authority to agree the final release
delegated to the assistant director
community and housing services and
consultation of the assistant director
legal services and a portfolio holder
for commune
thank you thank you have any questions
I'm sure I've got mr. way I can't mr.
hoy
Thank You Kim um this there's a acre so
doctors were raised in a minute
they obviously the figures throughout up
on this and they've got a claim under
stories nests over not to you we would
have chosen if it was in a gift to do
but this is something that's apparently
been offered to us that is why I want to
raise the next question I have concerns
over when we were approached when we
approached the people on this property
this went through planning at this
committee and I had heard rumors that we
were involved with it at that time that
we were advised that no we weren't and
so in police state at what point we were
aware that we would be or have been
offered this property to use thank you
when working on South Street with the
private developer we were advised that
they were looking at other local
property and we were asked whether there
was a continuing housing need and we
said yes there was the fact that they
made a decision to turn that into an HMO
was their decision we weren't involved
and we wouldn't have made any subsequent
and decision around housing homeless
households until such time that they
might have obtained any permission but
they asked us for housing need and we
said we've got one don't can we have the
actual date officially that we were very
interested thank you I have to be honest
with you I can't remember the actual day
but I'm sure I can get it for you if I
go back in my diary at the time we were
working on South Street a chairman I
certainly don't want to lose sight of
the fact this is going to be a very
important resource for residents of our
district who obviously you know fall on
times where they need support and
assistance so it's a good thing we do
and if we save money along the way
that's that's even better so I support
it I would have supported it as I did
support South Street and would have
supported others if they come forward
their concern I have and it's not a
concern that I personally became aware
of but it was a concern that was put to
me by a resident and probably another
one in concert to say that this building
obviously suffered a fire very recently
and to say is there any any any
situation in terms of the financial side
the rent we're paying that under writes
any of the repairs that were undertaken
as or will be undertaken as a result of
the fire because we shouldn't be doing
that
and that's something residents are
concerned to have an assurance upon that
there is no allowance within the rent to
in any way underwrite
renovations from the fire I can give my
categorical there's absolutely no in the
least cost there is no allowances for
any renovation crosses because of the
fire absolutely not and those costs have
yet to be decided and still being
discussed with the ashore as I
understand from the private developers
so I just need to give him my
reassurances about that something that
is so needed in our district and I'm
sure that when we are sitting here and
we're quite comfortable that sometimes
we forget that it could be us in need
and this is a resource that we
desperately need but I do have one
concern I have visited our homeless
providers in South End or West Cliff
I've visited South Street the
differential between those properties
that made a difference to the residents
according to the residents was the fact
that in both West Cliff and South End
there was a communal room and people in
this situation needs support and they
don't always want the support that
perhaps councils and officials can offer
they need the support of people in a
similar situation
peer support if you like and I would ask
the portfolio holder and the assistant
director to look at this and we're at a
relatively early stage and see if there
could be some communal space made for
the residents so that they can socialize
and assist each other because I think
that's as equally important as saving
money is the fact that they need other
sort of support think here
Joseph Smith Thank You chairman planning
was mentioned earlier not just for the
sake of clarity may make it absolutely
clear to all members that when this
applicator when when this property came
to planning it was determined wholly on
planning issues the end-users the lease
were not part of that decision in any
form thank you thank you thank you
chairman up how many in oh sorry
how many individual people can be
accommodated in these units are they all
one person thank you as detailed in the
report at the moment we're proposing
that all the units within the HMO are
for single occupancy so maximum 11
individuals as I see no other hand
indicating recommendation is that
council resolves that a 10-year lease be
entered into for the king's head 11 West
Street crossford and that authority to
agree the finalists be delegated to the
assistant director community and Housing
Services in consultation with the
assistant director of legal services and
the porthole portfolio holder for
communities that agreed members
the final item on the agenda item 14
allocation of seats on committees
it worked in there we go right chairman
I think we've got a revised appendix
that's come forward and has been tabled
here chairman I note one thing change is
in the appeals committee where you've
got one dear Liberal Democrat seat
instead of it being split over there
were Democrats from friends of Rochford
but there are two spaces I think for
conservative members as we now have 26
members and those are on the Investment
Board and on standards I would like to
produce that councillor FDB filling
those two spaces and the actually sits
on both of those committees already so
actually fits quite well mr. Mason
I didn't ever think I forgot to be
standing in this chamber in sight
by not being expecting to say this in
the chamber I am amazed to find that
someone leaves a group on this side of
the chamber and it reduces the
representation in my group the member
who has moved from friends of Rochford
to the conservative group has got
nothing to do with the green and rocks
for District residents group and yet the
number of allocation of total seats to
my group has actually been reduced by
one I don't understand it I'll be voting
against this and I want to take it
further there's a mr. boy Thank You
chairman I'm not sure I can throw that
off for you you might say much the same
thing the seat allocation for our group
is reduced by one from the report
produced in my group site hasn't changed
there is no change in our group
membership this is clearly wrong in my
mind that Friends of Rockford there's
one third of their members and retain
all of their seat will bar one nail it
would have here because they've never
changed it so I wrote some of this on
the committee's well about
proportionalities while we there's no
changes have lost a seat the only
conclusion I can draw is that our seats
have been calculated differently now
than they had been in mate where they
have been there should not be the case
and all the vote against recommendation
the issue I have in I've had extensive
discussions over the last few days with
Bose mr. to stop more mr. Bostock and
mr. scrutton
over this it around consistency there
appears to be no persistence over
whether or not we round up to a full
number we round up to a half a number or
we round down and
but only appears to be used in such a
way that we are being disadvantaged you
should buying it as I said before are
you voting nice thank you thank you any
other questions comments in that event I
moved to the recommendation Thank You
chairman and I had a brief conversation
with mr. Bostwick nice afternoon and
we've had this allocation see allocation
brought before us this this evening so I
just just want to be clear on what was
being proposed in that the allocation of
seats for friends of Rochford according
to this is for six seats one seats on
six of the committee's is that correct
the recommendation is that council
resolves that committee seat allocations
be as shown in the appendix to this
report is not agreed member I think
we'll take a vote I've just got to say I
think we'll take a vote on that all
those in favor please show
all those against
thank you any abstentions
that'd be the last item on the agenda
that's the I'll close the meeting at
8:47 thank you for your attendance safe
journey home please be upstanding the
chairman and the managing director will
leave the chamber thank you